Democratic candidate Joe Biden made a
pretty stunning campaign promise and I
want you to see this this is real take a
look I promise you if I'm elected
president you're gonna see the single
most important thing that changes
America's we're gonna cure cancer
[Applause]
that's right Biden promised to cure
cancer
now look trust me that's certainly an
admirable goal but many people are
saying the obvious that it wasn't a very
responsible thing to promise even worse
Joe Biden went on and promised all kinds
of things that many people are wondering
how he'll pull off for example Joe Biden
promised to reduce season eight of Game
of Thrones remove brown spots on bananas
make all toilet seats five degrees
warmer individually sue each and every
mosquito in the US mainland make Ohio an
oceanfront state add the name Gladys to
Mambo number five and bathing suit
chafing find out why raccoons have human
hands reduce the sound of corduroys
remove cantaloupe from fruit salad
harness sexual tension to heat us homes
and finally perhaps the toughest promise
from Biden stop putting his hands on
women shoulder
you